the Shannon sharp leaving
skip is really interesting
so skip leaves first take with Stephen A
starts a show on FSN and FS1 FS1 or
whatever yeah gets a bag
um supposed to be no name Channel nobody
gives a [__] about
builds it up into viral sensation
yeah finds an unbelievable talent in
Shannon Sharp
is memes Shannon is culture Shannon is I
mean sayings like his energy is
infectious I mean he's just incredible
uh uh Shannon decides that he no longer
wants to be part of the show
Leafs
why do you guys think that he left
I think Skip is insufferable after a
certain point
I think there's a lot of [__] you'll put
up with because skip
will have the crazy take that you can
bounce off of and you know how to play
with skip you'll elevate your profile
but I think and again I have listened to
skip since I was a kid in Dallas before
he was famous he started on Tiki wiki
when I started he started like when
taking Wiki started none of those guys
have really great experiences with skip
overall right so I just at a certain
point you're like you know what I don't
need this also the ratings on the show
weren't actually good Clips would go
viral but the ratings on the show itself
weren't that great so I think you're
just like I'll just go to the mouse at
ESPN oh do you think Shannon has offered
something over at the mouse I think he
can leverage something good out of this
and he's like I don't even put up with
this anymore the money thing yeah I
think for someone to leave like there's
got to be money somewhere else plus like
a hostile work environment like for some
reason for them to go and then some
other way to get the same or more money
somewhere else hmm I agree but there's a
combination of both like I want my own
thing I could probably get a bigger bag
someplace else I built up my name like I
people tune into the show probably for
me a little bit more like you see my
memes go crazy and he has his own
podcasts so he's really doing his solo
thing already yeah so yeah I think it's
just a play for the next venture I think
he probably
saw skip as a come up from the beginning
he probably knew what he was getting
into and then he I think that's why he
started doing Club Shay which is his
podcast early on as he built his thing
he started building for himself very
quickly I'm sure people talk to him and
he talked to people and he was like all
right this is what this is I don't know
how to play with this guy he'll say some
crazy [__] I'll have fun as me I'll use
him I'll raise my profile and then I'm
out
and I think Skip might be salty because
he's used to using
is he used to using I'm like I don't
know what I think what skipped it was
unbelievable he built it again
like he built First Take hasn't been the
same since skip they going through
different hoes you know it didn't work I
think it's still the highest rated show
regardless if it's rated it's not
culturally relevant in the way it was
with Stephen and Skip we can all
acknowledge that no here's where I give
some pushback I don't disagree with you
or think you're wrong but I think that
generation still cares about ratings
because that's what drives their
salaries being culturally relevant at
ESPN they haven't figured out how to
monetize that so they're going off of
who gives us ad dollars ratings gives us
ad dollars this show matters
yeah but one I don't think the ratings
are what they used to be they're not
yeah but that's TD exactly so what
matters to me is the cultural relevance
that you're going to get from all the
clips going viral on Instagram or
Twitter or different accounts picking
them up Etc like to me that's how I'm
looking at a show being successful and
then they have to find other ways to
monetize that but I'm like okay this is
this is success and the reality is like
Stephen A is a [__] Superstar but he
hasn't found that other person to bounce
off of in the same way that he did
Stephen A one of the best qualities that
he has is his ability to condescend
hilariously he is awesome at
condescending and he had the perfect
foil in skip a guy who is saying
absolutely ludicrous takes and then this
eloquent dude who is just kind of
staying the [__] out of him right tell
him why he's wrong and bullying him yeah
and it was magic and they haven't been
able to uh re uh replicate it I mean
they Max was too logical yeah Stephen
couldn't condescend it just came with
like logical facts every single time and
it's like this isn't entertaining you're
making a great argument I have to
[__] agree yeah and if you like it
just didn't work some of the funniest
clips is where people have cut up you
see skip arguing against himself oh yeah
have you seen skip arguing Aaron Rodgers
against himself yeah that's hilarious if
you can pull it up it's like it's not
it's unbelievable but he's pure
entertainment like that's the way I look
at him it's like he doesn't care about
sports he cares he is an actor yes he is
trying to say the funniest thing in the
moment I hope
Stephen A and sharp aren't behind the
scenes planning to do a show together
because I don't think it would work they
have too much respect for one another
they kind of play the same role on the
show yeah so it's like who's going to be
the skip I mean Steven they need someone
he could be an [__] too yeah and Skip
provides you all the opportunities to be
an [__] to him yes he is an [__]
so it's like it was magic and
yeah everybody else that they've matched
Stephen A with Stephen is just so
interesting that he's going to be able
to carry whatever the [__] he's on I
have no question about that but in order
to get
that [__] lightning rod that was
first take I mean it was you had to
watch it this is when nobody was
watching TV anymore everyone still
watched First Take are you watching
first take now
no I wasn't watching First Take ever but
yeah what oh yeah you never because I
said because I was like they're both
just playing characters as great as
Stephen A is he still I don't think he
believes everything he says I know Skip
doesn't believe anything he says so for
me it was like all right well I'll just
watch SportsCenter and see what's
actually happening but I know I'm the
exception because that was the highest
rated show on ESPN so I'm not saying I'm
right now what I will say is I do think
Stephen and Shannon could make it work
it won't be the same Dynamic at all I
don't think so but I think they're
talented and smart enough to make it
work I don't think so it'll be different
but I think it'll be good and also I
think Stephen A it's cool that he won't
ever dog out skip because what they did
together but he says Little Things
even just him saying like Steve a skip
came to me and begged me let's do a show
I need this we need this whatever and
then he had a message to Shannon on
video he's like Shannon hasn't told me
why he left I have a pretty good idea I
think I know I think Stephen A is taking
little shots at skip like he's
acknowledging working with skip sucks
but why do that after it's done
because you got to say something because
if you're in a shitty work environment
and you never at a certain point you
just you say little things that come out
it just happens ego unresolved tension
unresolved tension in my guess yeah more
than ego but ego for sure he's Stephen
A's great but he got an ego he'll tell
you that yeah so I think there's a
little bit of that hmm
yeah I hope that Stephen A and Shannon
don't do it together I don't think
that's the show I think Stephen A Needs
A pompous guy to talk to mm-hmm who was
that fat guy that gave horrible takes on
one of the other channels that chubby
black guy [__] oh yeah yeah oh Whitlock
yes Jason Whitlock Jason
that would be non-stop that would be
non-stop yeah between the two of them
that would be that would be great
fireworks I think Whitlock has just made
himself so toxic with some of his take
perfect
but he'll be so good but exactly that
that type of person who's gonna have
incredibly strong opinions that Stephen
A could condescend to and it would be
masterful but you have to be strong in
those I think there's a little bit
that's happening that with perk right
now yeah Perkins they found a little bit
of a dynamic right there
JJ Reddick is trying to make oh it's
amazing and you hear this heavy ass
breathing JJ Redick is on first take
yeah okay Stephen A JJ Redick and
Kendrick Perkins are all person is not
even on the screen you just hear this
breathing did getting ready because
making some really smart basketball
point he's amazing and then he goes stop
the midpoint he goes Park is that you
breathing what is that that's awesome
Stephen hey comes in he goes yeah are
you dying over there
I mean Sports commentary kind of needs
less facts yes it's inherently a
subjective thing like you're debating
people being good at like sports like
it's inherently like there's some data
but it's really kind of suggesting
that's why it's fun because there is no
right or wrong and so I think it's
almost better like who's the dude that
was like I'm taking Iguodala who was it
uh oh Max Kellerman yeah that was the
most illogical thing Max Kellerman has
ever said in the history and it's the
funniest thing he's ever said and it's
viral yeah it's like you almost want
less facts yeah that's why I skipped
commentary if we really want to call it
what it is
that's why it's kept the gold
[Music]
even a greatest in terms of like
journalism
skip is the greatest in terms of in
terms of creating an entertaining show
because he did it again
he recreated first take with a guy that
we all knew Shannon sharper we didn't
know him as a broadcaster and another
Superstar emerges they kept it bubbling
even once that guy left yeah because you
still nobody watches go go nobody
watches Undisputed every clip I watch
from Undisputed that goes viral that I
remember is Shannon
what I'm trying to say is he's the king
maker Shannon needs somebody to react to
what we like about Shannon is the
passion what we like about Shannon is
the excitement right and he's finding a
way to get that out of him give him
credit man you can't do it twice I mean
maybe the greatest B might great call
him a BMI yeah but again he's creating
the show right he created First Take
didn't he say I want Stephen A Smith no
I thought he Stephen A Smith had for
maybe I'm wrong I think Stephen A Smith
had first taken he was like get me on
this show no that's the way Stephen A
Smith tells it to skip like begging him
basically Oh I thought it was I'm not
doing the show unless it's with Stephen
A Smith that's what skip said I think
they both have different and then there
was a little tension because Stephen A
Smith told the story like that something
along the lines of what I said yeah and
Skip was annoyed by that and then
Stephen A Smith had to clear the air and
say this is what it was or whatever but
his retelling is I think Skip came to
him and said I need to do this
um but also just what I was gonna say
the moments I remember going viral from
Undisputed was Stephen A Smith he needs
to condescend with Shannon it's pulling
out the [__] Henny and the Black and
Mild and then just going Skip and that's
not even he'll do that with anybody Skip
Skip Skip it's just him being a [__]
character so here's my pushback on that
he has a podcast where he interviews
people yeah any clip that's going viral
from that podcast
is the guest
all the clips that go viral from the
show with him and Skip are him
and Skip is bringing something out of
him just like he brought the best most
entertaining version out of Stephen A he
brings the best most entertaining
version out of Shannon and if there's
someone else that they're gonna put in
there he's going to he's Bella check
dude he's gonna bring the best most
entertaining version out of the person
across from him and it's because he's so
[__] ridiculous you ever have someone
who's kind of like ball busty and mean
to you and then it gives you that like
that freedom to be an [__] to them
too and there's something liberating
about that like there's sometimes people
like really kind or nice or polite too
and you're like I can't [__] kill
this guy he forces you to kind of like
be polite be kind of polite but the fact
that somebody's coming in and just being
a jerk you could be like Oh I'm gonna
give all my opinions what we've built
with each other 100 right but we bring
out the best of each other
you see you sound like Pippin talking
about Jordan right now so like stop it
Stephen A is that dude no no no no
Stephen A's the greatest I said it right
to his [__] face right here I believe
he's the greatest but skip the best put
it this way
Stephen A
skip is Steve Nash everybody around skip
is gonna get a way bigger [__]
contract if you sit next to skip I'll
get paid
if you send next to Stephen A you might
get paid less
if you sit next to Stephen A you might
get paid man's making less money Steven
it could be Jordan skip could be Nash
Steven is Jordan okay
he's doing it but skip if you sit there
with him you have a career yeah as a
king maker a career maker I don't
disagree and again I don't like skip so
I'm gonna be hesitant to give up credit
but you I could see that and again I'm
not trying to give him credit as like
what he says is true yeah what I'm
saying is he's going to create an
environment where you're going to speak
to him in a way that is entertaining and
if you have skill he's gonna bring it
out of you and he's specifically looking
for people I think he's specifically
selecting people that he feels he can
have the most entertaining Dynamic with
and so far it works Gotta Give it up
because like uh the clip that's going
around that everybody's saying oh this
is maybe the reason why he left was when
they were talking about Brady and then
skip uh brings up
um sharp like yo yeah
like 30 something look at how he's
playing at 45 yeah and then he's like yo
why are you gonna take a personal shot
it's like yeah he dug it alone he knew
he was gonna yeah and that moment was
like this beautiful like vulnerable
authentic feeling right I'm just saying
skip these skip these flowers a bit too
for what he can create yeah not for the
journalism you can't be untalented and
be that big you can't beat an idiot and
get that big yeah twice to your point
got the bag and it's hard to get your
flowers if you're the heel a hundred
percent that's right he's the heel yeah
you have to look at him if it's
wrestling he's the heel and there can be
heels that are unbelievably popular but
without them you don't get the rock yeah
the rock needs someone to go against
yeah
so
the cool thing about Stephen A is he's a
uh lovable anti-antihero he's like Chael
Sonnen yeah yeah yeah yeah he's the
chill it's like he's he's almost trying
to be the heel but he's so good and so
lovable that you actually like him yeah
and you need somebody you need the
opposition to be very specific for that
yeah you need to be somebody who's like
even more of an [__]
yeah I'm trying to think of it like a
comparison between because I know
there's been players and coaches like
this with skip where you go there and
initially there's success and then
eventually this guy's personality will
wear out with everybody yeah and it's
gonna go up in Flames yep so this isn't
the right example but you could maybe
say something about oh Tara loans back
in the day Tio goes to your squad you're
gonna win games in the immediate future
you are going to win games he's going to
put up numbers at a certain point that
personality is going to destroy the
locker room yeah that's just what he did
everywhere dude Francisco did in Philly
he did in Dallas great call he's gonna
divide everyone and it's gonna be
[__] Up in Flames your quarterback
gonna have his best here yeah yeah tight
end gonna have his best here you know
what I mean and then eventually he gonna
start calling Jeff Garcia gay or calling
Donovan mcnabb's vet yes yes it's just
what is going to be and that's gonna
wear on you yeah but yes that's great
great example
speaking of uh little hot takes did you
guys see the game game two I did I did
yes yes yes okay yes a little bit no
come on we know I didn't but it was a
good idea
so he caught you during the I don't do
you like went to him he's like oh yeah
yeah